apple just showed off the brand new ipad
os 15. in this video
we're not only going to test out some of
the best new features
i will also show you some features that
they didn't talk about
that make a world of a difference with
your ipad experience especially with the
new ipad pros
but we'll also talk about some major
disappointments and issues with ipad os
some things that were not fixed some
other issues and
a couple big ones that literally might
not make it worth having one of these
new m1 ipad
pros so let's start out with something
very simple
and light-hearted but this was a major
issue with the new ipad
15 killer feature we have a vertical
iphone app so you no longer have to take
your ipad off
rotate it to see or kind of turn your
head you can actually see the app
the proper way and you can maximize it
like this
so it fills up more of the screen and
the next groundbreaking new feature that
we've really asked for
is the app library see it's always stuck
here
in your dock and you can open up and
these apps are automatically sorted for
you to find them
easily of course i'm just having a
little bit of fun here guys
that was added i don't think we need
that let me show you how to remove it
you can go into your home screen and
docs settings tap show app library and
doc
and just like that it is gone just in
case you don't want it there
now the next one is legitimately nice to
have and this is update we should have
had and
this really harnesses the m1 performance
in this ipad pro and that is
widgets before we only had it on the
left hand side
now widgets could be placed anywhere you
want just like android had about
10 years ago but this is actually a
legitimately cool function
where you can go in you have a bunch of
widgets here you can search we have
brand new ones for
mail you have ones for game center if
you want to add them they're nice and
large
find my is definitely going to be useful
if you want to track where your items
are if they're nearby
and especially the files app this one
definitely could be nice so you have to
go into there
you can literally just add it to
wherever you want let's go ahead and
move that to a separate page
so this is legitimately a great addition
you can set up one screen for
productivity you can have a calendar
stocks anything else you want there
another page for
gaming entertainment and it does make
the ipad a lot more productive now this
next one
is a killer one that apple did not
mention let's go ahead and plug in my
external ssd
and let me go into my files app and this
was a huge frustration for a lot of
people now let me tell you guys there's
still a lot of issues with filezap that
i will talk about in just a bit
but one of the benefits is that we now
finally get a progress bar
when we are transferring files let me
tell you how frustrating that is to not
see how long it's going to take
here we have this typical app kind of a
progress bar
but then we can go in and get even more
info so here i can finally see
one how much data is being transferred
how far i'm at and how much
longer it's gonna take for that transfer
to happen yesterday i was waiting
ten more or even more minutes hoping for
it to finish
and i'm just sitting there waiting not
knowing how long it's going to take
that's been extreme frustration so
finally that has been fixed now one
thing i'm extremely curious about
is the performance with ipad os 15. if
you guys saw our previous video
where the same exact drive connected to
an m1
ipad pro with thunderbolt it took way
way longer
than connected to a macbook to transfer
the same exact
files that was a frustration it takes a
while
so i'm actually going to be doing a
separate video going over performance of
ipad os 14 versus 15.
we're not only going to look at transfer
speeds we're going to see if
new drives are able to connect we'll
also compare the performance with
certain apps that were actually
slower with the m1 ipad pro than with
the older 2020 ipad that had the a12 z
processor in general performance such as
geekbench and other programs
as well so if you guys want to see that
video go ahead and click that subscribe
button down below
and with that you can help us reach our
goal of 1 million subscribers
before the end of this year we would
greatly appreciate it the next
legitimately exciting feature
are web extensions and not the basic
ones that we already have that you can
download
but full featured web extensions where
it works just like on your mac
it has a lot more control um so this is
going to be exciting finally we're going
to have
decent safari support just like we have
on mac os
next we have on device siri that also
works
offline this means your audio stays on
your ipad
and it works faster set a timer for 30
minutes
30 minutes there you go believe it or
not that would not work before unless
you're connected to the internet so siri
is getting faster
and smarter and i have been starting to
use it more so and this will definitely
help with that for these next ones let's
attach
the magic keyboard and the first ones
that i want to show off are the new
commands with a full-size full-featured
keyboard
so as you guys could see we can switch
between apps but now we have this
little option where you hold down
command and it gives you a
full list of keyboard shortcuts now this
isn't just to
remind you how to do simple things in a
lot of apps
there are so many keyboard shortcuts and
different options that you don't see
just by using the app alone you guys
look through luma fusion here
how much different awesome options that
we have and you don't have to actually
use the shortcut you can open this up
and then select oh i want to add a
voiceover bam select that
all sudden and now we're getting ready
to do our voiceover
that is amazing and it's going to make
apps especially these higher end ones so
much easier to use and learn
and then we have the groundbreaking
universal control
which was actually talked about during
the mac section and that allows you to
literally wirelessly without any setup
move a cursor
from your mac to your ipad and back now
as you guys can see it is not currently
working
with this first beta version but apple
showed it off
and literally it's like magic now not
only can you do that
to access different apps and use two
screens which you can just already use
sidecar on your mac if you're just using
your mac but if you're drawing if you're
creating an ipad
you can drag whatever that is directly
into mac os
drop it and it transfers instantly
and this is just what is so awesome
about having the apple
ecosystem now that also tells us that
apple doesn't really want the ipad to be
an all-in-one
device they want you to have an ipad pro
for two thousand dollars maybe a macbook
for 1500
maybe even an imac as well for when
you're at your desk
they want you to spend as much money as
possible of course they are a company
that makes a lot of money
but that just kind of shows you their
direction before i show you what i think
is probably the coolest new feature
let's talk about multitasking it's not
really a new feature
this is a fix probably what we should
have had
right at the gate it's so much easier to
use now for example we have lumafusion
opened up right here
instead of having stuff in the dock
pulling and it doesn't work very well
literally litigate tap at the top bam
and you can see you can slide it over
one side another
or even more simple just drag it down it
moves over select the other thing you
want to have
bam we're all set up right there and
then you can also go in
this is another great way to do it you
have a couple multitasking
set up right here let's say we want to
go settings with imovie
and then you can actually just come in
grab an app that you want
place it right over another app bam
very easy very quick to use you can go
over and switch over
to other ones this is just how it should
have been out of the gate
very simple very easy and much more
usable and now probably the coolest
legitimately new feature that
elevates the ipad way more from the
macbook now
is a new quick note function you just
pull down from that corner
right away you can write anything you
want let's see
my handwriting is terrible you're gonna
write that
and then as soon as you're done you can
just pull it away bam it is
gone and it saves to a special function
and what's even cooler is
when you're researching you can actually
pull it up you can write a note you can
add the link
to where you're at if you highlight text
and then you
add that to your quick note when you
later go back to that and you actually
click
on the link it will go to that page and
it will actually
have that highlighted to show you
exactly where that is
at that section and what's even cooler
is that when you go
later to visit a page that you were
writing notes on
researching whatever and you go to that
exact page
that note will pop up right here for you
to see
what you wrote what you were writing
down on there it is just saved and this
is system
y so for people that like taking notes
not only do we have
these features notes is a lot more
powerful you have collaboration tools
now
you can update and tag somebody it is
awesome and
that is it for the best new features
let's
go ahead and put the magic keyboard away
i know that list wasn't that big you
might have been expecting
more and i think a lot of us from the
apple event from wwc
we're expecting more from ipad os 15
especially with these new m1 macbook pro
so let's talk about
the issues that ipad os has now the
biggest one what a lot of us waiting for
are
actual pro apps for this pro tablet such
as final cut
or xcode now i know some of you guys say
hey this is not
a laptop replacement apple doesn't want
it to be
this is an ipad that can do a lot of
things but you should also own a mac
and although i think it'd be cool if
they can have final connects code i wish
those apps would come especially with 16
gigs of ram and stuff on this machine
i'm not asking for a full laptop
replacement or full mac os
even just fixes to certain issues that
still
are have not been fixed would be great
for example this is one i thought would
definitely get
fixed with this new hardware and this
new thunderbolt port
and that is being able to use whatever
drive you want to
connect now we had issues with our
thunderbolt drive here
some work some don't and unfortunately
with this new beta we can go into the
files app
and this download drive still does not
show up in the files app
whereas my other one does so i can't use
it let's plug this other drive into here
you'll see that it came up here on the
left hand side i can access my files on
here
but there's nothing that i could do to
completely erase it change the format
i could just delete things that are
actually on the drive itself now another
issue is not being able to eject
your ssds and i think that's very
important
apple says and people are saying that
you just eject it whenever you want to
you just pull it out
but i've actually had recently two
corruption issues where i eject the
drive
and then i go to plug it back in and it
doesn't show up i had that
yesterday as well with this ipad and
then i have to go to a laptop a macbook
plug it in and then run the first aid
software that can fix the drive it takes
about 10 minutes to go through and fix
it so that would be great to have that
option just so you know
that it's ejected and there aren't going
to be any issues now this next one is a
big deal for me personally i don't know
about you guys but when i'm being
productive
i like to listen to music in the
background or for example a podcast
and you can do certain things like
having it play in the background and you
know browse the web as long as there's
no autoplay
music or ads or anything that turns on
and for example yesterday i was doing
some video editing and as soon as you
actually start
playing your video that background audio
completely
shuts off you can no longer listen to a
podcast and go through and cut footage
do things like that now of course you
can't multitask but even here
if you keep youtube open or whatever and
you start playing back your footage
bam that is pause there's no way to have
two separate audio sources playing at
the same time like you could on a mac
you know lower down your volume for your
background music do some editing do some
whatever else you're doing that might
have audio in it it just automatically
disables it
the same thing with picture-in-picture
mode as soon as you start playing back
another source of audio
that gets shut off and this is just one
example if you're browsing the web you
know there's the autoplay ad or
something else plays you want to
quickly turn something on it just gets
cancelled out and this next one we
for sure thought was going to get fixed
when these new machines came out this
was an issue and people are
just saying just wait for ipados 15.
it's right around the corner
we're going to get this pro ipad it's
going to work properly and that is
external display
support even with this new machine when
you plug it in
it still does not fill that whole screen
of this crazy expensive display
i'm really not sure why this wasn't
added apple's busy
adding different eye colors for
different emojis so you can swap that
you can you know send pictures of your
dog from your apple watch
stuff like that but yeah two thousand
dollar tablet
actually connecting properly to a
display without these black bezels
is not really an option and of course
with that if they're not able to give us
that
you still can't use your ipad in
clamshell mode so if you buy an ipad it
works for almost everything you do or
everything
you want to connect it to an external
keyboard trackpad or mouse and a display
and work
in that way it is also not an option
just shuts
off you cannot use that way like you can
you know a 900
macbook air and then the last one that i
have that
a lot of people were hoping on
especially professionals that love this
beautiful mini led display that is ultra
bright for hdr content
is being able to use it connect it to
your mac
to edit your footage and view it in hdr
this for 1100 bucks even if you're just
buying it for the display alone
is great instead of buying a 5 000
6000 display you can use this at least
that's
that was what the hope was but no you
still
cannot view hdr content on it through
side car and that's a part of ipad os
even if you connect it
through thunderbolt an actual the cable
as soon as you bring footage onto it
it just plays back in regular sdr
not hdr and same thing with final cut
when you connect uh to it
you do not have that option like you do
with apple's pro display so it kind of
seems like apple
does not want people to be able to buy
these tablets for
the ability to maximize you know this
display and actually use it to its
potential which is
editing hdr content or even hdr photos
they want you to buy that very expensive
hdr display the
6k xdr that they sell and that is
definitely a major
bummer for those that bought this
thinking hey we can actually use this
with sidecar
it's going to work great this is the
awesome solution apple is providing
well that is not what ipad os 15
is offering us so there you guys go we
have some legitimately
great features that can help day-to-day
speed things up
improve your experience give us
capabilities that make it
much easier to use and also some major
issues that still have not been fixed
that
ruin the experience on the ipad even if
you spend a ton
for this crazy powerful m1 ipad pro
let me know your guys's thoughts and
once again if you guys want to see that
performance comparison between ipad os
14
and ipad os 15 the external drives
general performance make sure you guys
click that circle above to subscribe
and that will help us reach a million
subscribers before that year we would
greatly appreciate it
this has been max and i'll see you in
the next video